hello I'm Conan O'Brien I recently had
the great privilege to perform for our
troops stationed in the Middle East
country of Qatar at the Al Udeid Air
Base over 10,000 coalition troops are
stationed at a low deed and they work
tirelessly around the clock helping to
launch and execute a constant stream of
air missions departing from the base my
trip to a low deed began with a phone
call from the White House first lady
Michelle Obama was going to visit the
base as part of the joining forces
initiative she asked me if I'd come
along and put on a show for the troops I
immediately said yes before I knew it I
was flying to Washington DC to hitch a
ride with mrs. Obama now obviously due
to security reasons I was unable to
bring a video camera on the jet but I
can still show you what happened on our
flight with the help of state-of-the-art
incredibly expensive 3d animation after
taking off from Washington our flight
began in typical fashion the first lady
did some work on her laptop well I've
read the in-flight magazine on birdie
Eagle which featured an article about
Joe Biden's favorite quality more steak
house next it was time for a beverage
the first lady had her usual one can of
tomato juice while I had my usual all
the vodka on the plane I figured I'd
visit the pilots and give them the
thrill of a lifetime but two secret
servicemen choices warned me that
standing in the cockpit was not advised
that made me drop one of my vodka
bottles would somehow affected the plane
luckily the first lady quickly took over
the controls and then made sure I was
safely back in my seat after landing on
a Portuguese fishing schooner I was
forced for weeks to earn my keep until
eventually we laid anchor in the port of
Jeddah Saudi Arabia from there I began
the 1500 kilometer hike to cut up along
the way I was captured by bandits and
sold into a harem despite a quickly
becoming
I escaped and continued my journey but I
have run out of water and just when all
seemed lost
I saw a mirage it was the first lady
coming to rescue me and take me to rest
away to the Al Udeid Air Force Base
where I would finally get to perform for
our troops
[Applause]
[Applause]